[Música]
quem for ao parque são muito bem vindos
mais um vídeo e mostrados aqui estou
aqui em causa uma pipoca quentão que não
sabia que queria ter vencido um set com
uma pessoa quer aprender tanto assim que
ela tem 50 graus e 20° 300 graus 400
graus 500 graus e 600 graus pagar botão
duas portas a pistola eu comprei um
utensílio que tipo mas é basicamente com
base em quanto isso léo vai indicar a
temperatura aqui está um objeto com
apenas um ponto lá está na abordagem que
tem sido só uma abundância ter coisas
com nota pessoal atenta e depois o
governo tem muitas coisas estão não têm
esse país quando a empresa ter e não
cola mais mellon 4 que é o nosso amigo
chocolate e de certeza que a polícia tem
que falar que tenho que manter a atitude
vai só até duas das três escolas ligadas
para fazer meus pecados do dia e por que
dois já mudou completamente a estrutura
da garrafa mesmo
o places parece aquelas embalagens de
vidro não gosta de tocar coisas 21 vai
abrir um blog eu sou daqui 91° 85 92 90
graus para abrir um buraco na garrafa
[Aplausos]
não será esse foi também colocada aí
então quem diria que espera uma
embalagem de coca cola da bastilha
temperatura experimentaram 150° o evento
morro
[Aplausos]
vejam só que vamos tentar fazer o mesmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
com o sol
coloque embaixo de tudo o que sobe tanto
a coca cola está a subida que aproxima a
copa se falar em cima tá aqui pra baixo
é um ciclo na escola
o dolo muito lucro pessoal esta é a
nossa coca cola ficou muito bem
vamos tentar que a meta dos 100 mil mais
que o primeiro eu vou tentar ter coisas
loucas aqui com a nossa escola dentro do
meu concelho nas casas tenham ativo que
se coisas e baterias coisas podem não
muita coisa louca em seu voto gosto
questão saber se ele tem alguma idéia
low kicks eu não tenho esse brinquedo de
plástico não pode achar que vai
acontecer né
vamos lá tentar saltar de 350 graus
revelou que fumar vai abrir mão ou então
eu
[Aplausos]
luisão lúcio e seguro a vítima salvar
aquele que o marcelo e vamos fazer umas
pitadas marcello cusatis 2003 mas não
vamos usar o melhor lance do são paulo
na roupa
joão aroso para o terceiro gol que bom
que acredita que merece 31 graus não
está muito quente né
todos um só viram a vitória em casa o
fato mas ao mesmo tempo temos muito
goleiro saulo silva gostoso haver uma
bolha
[Aplausos]
não escolha será atribuída nota falsa
joga tem produtos para 70 graus
aqui é coisa mais claro porque só que
aqui tá louco de então comer só roda
muito bom muito bom mesmo testado para
um título aqui 44 tentar abrir um buraco
no meio e tentar não tem mal que planeja
abrir um buraco profundo bahia que
acontece após acusar ser aqui do lado
para tentar melhorar o carro
[Aplausos]
completamente entupido de tudo vou
tentar fazer aqui uma mini cozinha
21 sofreu a sua história segundo toque
mais 12 ataque mais o ou completamente
do ritmo muito bom e duro do 4° - de
usar não é improvável
foi o que aconteceu
[Música]
vamos ficar até os 100 mil likes neste
vídeo exatamente não entrem conquistou
80 mil é muito perigoso aquele lá vocês
vão ter dois filhos provavelmente
diminuirão em cima das podem ser que
amanhã até a próxima